[Music]  lastly we did our shows in Chicago we  had a great time one interesting thing  we learned about the city everyone  Chicago is very mad you learn about that  their tallest building the Sears Tower  has been renamed the Willis Tower yeah  Chicagoans they they want their Sears  Tower back so as a parting gift we went  ahead and we picked another building to  carry on the mighty Sears Tower name  it's a dippin dot stand on Chicago's  Navy Pier now if you were from Chicago  you'd be laughing right now let's take a  look at the dedication ceremony they are  cutting the ribbon there it is Chicago's  new Sears Tower  it has over one story in height as an  employee only restroom you can see that  the crowd is excited to see this check  out the amazing view from the  observation deck yes the new Sears Tower  our gift to the city that we were in for  a few days  [Music]